sue is a software engineer she wants to
create a large scale drawing of a
processor inside a cell phone the
processor is a square chip nine
millimeters on each side draw the
processor such that one unit on the grid
below represents one half of a
millimeter all right so let's just think
about these two worlds you have the
drawing and you have the chip in the
real world the drawing we're thinking in
terms of these units here on this graph
paper so units and the chip we're
thinking in terms of millimeters and so
we can set up a table here and they tell
us draw it such that one unit represents
half a millimeter so one unit would
represent one half of a millimeter they
tell us that the processor is nine
millimeters on each side so that is how
many times as many millimeters well to
go from one half to nine you have to
multiply by 18 so that's going to be 18
times as many units as well so if I want
to do a scale drawing right over here
it's going to be a square it's a square
chip and since the scale is one unit it
represents half a millimeter 18 units
would represent nine millimeters and so
I would want to do 18 units on a side so
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 so that would be the left side of
the chip let me just see if I can draw a
straight line there just like that and
then it would also be 18 wide 18 units
wide representing 9 millimeters in the
real world
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 this is making my eyes hurt
all right so just like that and then I
could draw the other parts of it it
would be like that and then I would just
go straight down like that and there you
have it I have drawn a scale drawing of
our processor and we are all done